all right I am so freaking excited
because I'm about to have what I believe
is the best ramen in the world it's my
favorite the last time I came back to
Hawaii we ate at this place and it was
so good I had it for dinner three days
in a row and then I went back to the
mainland and looked for the same style
at Superman which is like the dry style
and I tried about five different places
and none of them even come close so when
I came back to Hawaii I had to get it
one more time before I leave not to
mention this little Duty loves noodles
are you ready for some noodles for lunch
on the background first
oh man
doesn't work
oh man it just took the dollar straight
up no we'll keep well we pushed this
thing yeah but it's an emergency thing
so just stop it oh so it would have
started going but it stopped it yeah are
you gonna put another dollar in no
that's all you gotta say it just doesn't
work
so this restaurant is in the Ala Moana
mall which is one of the biggest malls
in Oahu and I'm actually really happy
that they moved here because back at the
other location it was underground and so
parking was kind of a paint and also
because the space was so small you would
have to wait for like two three hours
every single time but now that it's in a
food court as you can see behind me the
seating is endless so
as I can see there is no line which I'm
extremely happy and we're here
bam paper paper
check it out
look at all the ramens they got they got
lots of ramen garlic
and the Superman Ramen right there oh
yeah
so all of these are really good because
of their thick noodle it's like almost
like a cross between Ramen and Hunan but
what I specifically get is the number
14. they got the softball egg and then
they got the pork and the chashu we got
a ton of protein and then I get it with
the extra noodle because it's so
freaking good I can eat literally just
the noodles and just the broth and you
want to make sure you get the tsukumen
one because this is the one that's the
dippy one this is the one that's crazy
bomb the other one's still good too
where the noodles come in the broth but
this one specifically man when you dip
those noodles and that concentrated like
Flavor broth is so freaking good
the monkey we're about to eat Papa's
favorite noodles in the whole world
are you excited to try Papa's favorite
noodles yeah
I like how he cares about the buzzer
more than how it tastes did you just eat
that that's disgusting these balls off
are you kidding me
I thought I was able to share my joy of
these noodles with them because these a
fellow noodle lover
but I guess I won't be able to
so this is the miracle broth right here
it is so good look at all that chopped
garlic you see that
smell it Mama
oh my Lord
so I got that and then we get the
noodles see how thick it is and you dip
it in there so you take as much as you
want out and you put it in but you don't
dump the whole thing in and that's the
whole experience and we got an extra
little bowl for the young tights okay
he's so sleepy I know it's nap time huh
all right here we go the moment I've
been waiting for so the meat I do like
to throw the meat in there because it
gets all nice and flavored up
if I soak it in there mix up the garlic
a little bit oh but look at these
noodles these are the thick noodles that
I have never found anywhere else
dip it in like that
pull it out
I really forgot how good they were it's
kind of unfortunate it's in the Copic
packaging they saw that protocol because
when it comes out piping hot in a bowl
that's porcelain that's hot oh man oh
man these noodles babe you're missing
out just by recording me
even though I told you to record me
but man
what happened
is it yummy Mister yeah
this is truly a spiritual experience for
me what about for you nah it's whatevers
like when it's like fatty stuff yeah it
doesn't sit too happy for you but yeah
like for me it just I hates it look at
this guy
that's good
yeah for me type one the chashu it's
like you tastes the smokiness so you
could tell they like really spend a lot
of quality on every single ingredient
from the softball a
the trash you the garlic of the broth to
the AL denteiness of the noodles and you
combine like three top
quality ingredients combine them all man
it's a spiritual
experience look at this look at this
this guy's speaking in tongues
did you just go to heaven
you don't even know what that means to
Crazy Bones
thank you